Hello, and welcome to this course, Behaviour Trees and State Machines.
Now, the project files for this and all the instructions will be based on Unreal Engine 5.5.
However, most of the functionality has been pretty consistent all the way since 5.1,
so this should work in other versions of the engine.
From this course, it's divided into two parts. We're going to be the first half,
we're going to look at behaviour trees, and the second half we're going to look at state machines.
So we aim from this that you will be able to understand what both types of the AI are,
and also that you'll be able to set it up, and to choose between and select the version
which is going to be most appropriate for you. With this course, there comes a project file,
and this project file is going to be quite important. We recommend that you download it
and run the project. It's designed as two exercises. The first exercise is going to be
setting up a behaviour tree, and the second exercise is going to be setting up a state
machine. So we really do recommend that you download the project and follow along
with the exercises as we go through this. Thank you very much.